zum ersten mal in der geschichte der
menschheit schicken wir voraussichtlich
ende november eine waffe in den weltraum
um die verteidigung der erde zu proben
die mission dort startet zum doppel
asteroiden die kinos um auf dem
kleineren begleiter des haupt asteoriden
einzuschlagen wir freuen uns dieses
thema von pm mit exklusivem material aus
dem aktuellen heft übernehmen zu können
in zusammenarbeit mit dem magazin gibt
es übrigens auch noch ein hammer
gewinnspiel bei dem ihr einen
programmierbaren roboter gewinnen könnt
also los geht's
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen und ein riesen dank
an pm das magazin pm und unser kanal
ticks umsatz in futures haben etwas
gemeinsam und zwar die begeisterung und
leidenschaft für wissenschaft und die
redaktion liegt genauso viel wert auf
gute recherche wahrheit und fakten für
die ungeduldigen ist der link zum
gewinnspiel übrigens hier unterliegen
der infobox und im ersten angriff decken
kommentar wenn man sich da weiter klickt
kommt man auch zu den genauen
teilnahmebedingungen es ist tatsächlich
wie in einem katastrophenfilm und das
ist nicht übertrieben die erde wird
unablässig mit asteroiden bombardiert
die in die atmosphäre eindringen und
hier explodieren rund zwei mal pro jahr
wird der energie mehrere atombomben das
veröffentlichte die stiftung wie 612
2014 die stiftung hat sich zur aufgabe
gemacht schwerer so liegen einschläge zu
verhindern doch meistens können diese
einschläge nicht beobachtet werden 2009
10 gelang es ausnahmsweise das
eindringen eines zehn meter brockens zu
beobachten er explodierte über der
beringsee mit der energie von zehn
hiroshima atombomben sie dringen fast
immer über unbewohnten gebieten ein 2013
war das anders und 1 20 meter großer
brocken explodierte mit der energie von
30 euro china bomben in einer höhe von
25 kilometern über russland in der 65
kilometer entfernten stadt tscheljabinsk
verletzte die druckwelle
1500 menschen die aktuelle situation ist
folgende wenn wir mit teleskopen objekte
am himmel ausmachen würden die sich auf
kollisionskurs mit der erde befinden
hätten wir kaum eine chance dieses
tödliche schicksal noch abzuwenden
konkrete abwehrmaßnahmen
assistieren bisher nämlich nur auf dem
papier doch genau das soll sich jetzt
ändern da steht für doppel s kreuth
redirection testo die nasa will mit
diesem manöver schon zwischen september
und oktober 2022 ein spektakuläres und
neuartiges verfahren so hast du ihnen
abwehr testen das ziel wird der ära
doppel astrid 65 80 3 sein er wurde 1996
entdeckt und wenig später fiel dann auf
dass es sich bei dem objekt um einen
doppel körper handelt deswegen sein name
die demos die griechische bezeichnung
für zwilling der größere brocken von
beiden hat einen durchmesser von 800
metern der kleinere einen durchmesser
von etwa 160 metern er heißt die more
fonds und wird manchmal auch als die ki
moon bezeichnete er umkreist den
größeren die die most körper in einer
entfernung von 1,1 kilometer und braucht
für eine umrundung rund 11,9 stunden das
zielobjekt ist aktuell keine bedrohung
für unsere erde und damit ein ideales
testobjekt wenn beim test etwas schief
geht hat das keine konsequenzen für die
erde das nasa manöver dient lediglich
dazu und für den ernstfall vorzubereiten
die flugbahn änderung von dee dee moore
soll durch die 600 kilogramm schwere
raumsonde tat ausgelöst werden im nasa
kann zur folge trifft sie mit sechs
kilometern pro sekunde auf den
asteroiden an bord hat sie ein
navigationssystem und eine bordkamera
damit sie ihr ziel auf jeden fall nicht
verfehlt wir haben ausgerechnet dass wir
mit wenigstens 95 prozent
wahrscheinlichkeit treffen sonst würden
wir gar nicht starten bei simulationen
am boden haben wir sogar 100 prozent
erreicht so die leitende ingenieurin
elena dass der aufprall würde nach den
berechnungen der nasa eine veränderung
der bahn geschwindigkeit von dem nun um
etwa 0,4 millimeter pro sekunde bewirken
auch wenn das zunächst nach einer
minimalen veränderung klingt wäre solch
eine neuausrichtung groß genug um sie
mit teleskopen von der erde aus zu
messen denn die auswirkungen wären
erheblich vor dem aufschlag braucht der
dimb und 11,9 zwei stunden für eine
umrundung die sonde wird den mond
entgegen seiner umlaufbahn treffen sie
nimmt also ihm einen teil seines
schwungs dabei fällt die mossos
eine tiefere und damit schnellere bahn
seine umlaufzeit ist dann um etwa 10
minuten kürzer während eine bahn
änderung des haupt asto ihn nur sehr
schwer und wahrscheinlich erst monate
oder sogar jahre später beobachtet
werden könnte kann die veränderung der
umlaufbahn bei die kommunen direkt von
der erde aus beobachtet werden dafür
müssen wir die licht kurve des
asteroiden dessen licht wird jedes mal
schwächer wenn der mond vor die die most
of pop tat die umlaufzeit von die
dämonen die gewünschten verkürzt hat
werden also teleskope schon nach wenigen
tagen offen fragen dieses manöver würde
zeigen ob wir mit solch einer mission
tatsächlich auch einen asteroiden der
sich auf kollisionskurs mit der erde
befindet erfolgreich um lenken können
denn fest steht schon eine kleine
flugbahn änderung eines asteroiden
könnte das fortbestehen der erde
sicherstellen denn das ist entscheidend
um so weiter der astor entfernt ist und
so länger es noch bis zu einem möglichen
einschlag auf der erde dauert desto
geringer muss die flugbahn verändert
werden um eine katastrophe zu verhindern
elf millionen kilometer wird das
asteroiden zwillings system zum
zeitpunkt des aufpralls von dort von der
erde entfernt sein damit die sonde die
mündlich erreichen kann wird sie jetzt
im november 2000 21 starten was aber
auch das letzte zeitfenster für eine
erfolgreiche mission ist dazu mit lee
johnson von der nasa klar wäre die erste
mission der nasa welche die sogenannte
kinetik inspector technik demonstriert
einen asteroiden mit einem gezielten
einschlag von seiner umlaufbahn zu
schieben um sich gegen einen möglichen
zukünftigen asteroiden ein stadt zu
verteidigen eine echte premiere also
wenn beide geht es nicht wie bei
bisherigen missionen darum
wissenschaftliche daten zu den us open
zu sammeln wie bei den beiden asteroiden
besuchen der nasa-raumsonde unseres rex
und der japanischen asahi die mission
eier butter 2 wir hatten darüber
berichtet stattdessen handelt es sich
bei der daten mission sage und schreibe
um die erste planetare verteidigungs
mission überhaupt und so werden nicht
nur boden teleskope eingesetzt um den
aufprall und dessen folgen genau zu
beobachten auch die europäische
weltraumorganisation esa ist mit am
start und auch sie plant eine raumsonde
zum die teams zu schicken er soll
allerdings erst 2023 starten und dort
folgen dann könnte sie wichtige daten zu
dem die muss asteroiden sammeln die esa
möchte zudem einen nano satelliten auf
die die nun aufsetzen lassen der dem von
dort erzeugten krater genau vermessen
soll der länder juventus ist zwölf
kilogramm schwer und etwa so groß wie
ein schuhkarton er soll zusammen mit
hera sowie was soeben fliegen und zudem
auch mit radam das innere von peking nun
analysieren denn auch die innere
struktur und die
oberflächenbeschaffenheit eines
himmelskörpers entscheiden maßgeblich
darüber wie sich dieser beim aufprall
eines objektes verhält genau deswegen
sind auch diese erkenntnisse enorm
wichtig um die neue technologie zur
abwehr von asteroiden zu perfektionieren
wir haben bei pixum sunsim future schon
über verschiedene techniken zu hast du
ihnen abwehr berichtet man könnte eine
atomrakete zu einem asteroiden schicken
allerdings könnte die das problem
verschlimmern der asteroid würde den
zahlreichen brocken zerfallen von denen
dann größere die erde sogar mit 100
prozentiger wahrscheinlichkeit treffen
oder man könnte sie in der nähe das
asteroiden explodieren lassen und ihm so
einen schubs geben eine andere idee ist
die eines graffiti traktors ein
möglichst schweres raumfahrzeug wird in
der nähe des asteroiden platzieren um
mit seiner gewichtskraft den brocken aus
der bahn zu ziehen oder man montiert ein
triebwerk auf dem asteroiden um ihn von
seinem kollisionskurs abzubringen china
plant 23 raketen typ langer marsch auf
einen ast soliden abzufeuern in den usa
ist die nasa behörde namens planetary
die fans koordination office maßgeblich
an der entwicklung solcher konzepte
beteiligt sie wurde erst 2016 gegründet
noch im sommer 2018 hatte die nasa ein
ausführliches strategiepapier zu
asteroiden abwehr vorgelegt demnach
müssen dringend möglichkeiten entwickelt
werden mit denen die flugbahnen von
gesteinsbrocken beeinflusst werden
können auch hier betont die nasa noch
einmal dass die wahrscheinlichkeit für
einen einschlag zwar gering ist doch die
folgen umso katastrophaler bisher sind
25.000 erdnahe asteroiden entdeckt
worden und rund 10.000 haben einen
durchmesser von 140 metern und 900 sind
größer als einen kilometer aber selbst
viele kleinere asteroiden können der
erde gefährlich werden der asteroid der
über chelyabinsk explodiert ist hatte
einen durchmesser von lediglich 20
metern und hat trotzdem schwere schäden
angerichtet und ab 50 metern durchmesser
schlagen asteroiden auf dem boden auf
und reißen einen krater von einem
kilometer durchmesser auf und es werden
immer mehr im moment entdecken wir im
durchschnitt jede nacht ungefähr sieben
neue erdnahe objekte so detlef koschny
leiter des planetary die fans office der
esa und jetzt gibt es diesen hammer
roboter zu gewinnen der krypton 6 von
felix der über diverse sensoren verfügt
wie zum beispiel compass group mikrofon
und viele mehr und programmiert werden
kann ziemlich spannend außerdem gibt es
obendrauf auch noch zwei gratis ausgaben
des magazins pm inklusive der aktuellen
ausgabe dafür einfach hier auf sie
klicken oder auf den link im ersten
kommentar oder in der video beschreibung
kleiner geheimtipp die chance zu
gewinnen sind ziemlich gut und in der
aktuellen ausgabe gibt es noch viel mehr
infos zur daten mission und noch viele
weitere super interessante themen aus
der wissenschaft und forschung zum
beispiel berichtet pm über eine hightech
folie die wie eine klimaanlage wirkt
aber das vollkommen ohne energie über
drogen und warum die menschen früher
wussten heroin nahmen um bonbons aus
kokain bei zahnschmerzen und überleben
unter der erde unter absolut
lebensfeindlichen bedingungen und warum
das auch auf außerirdisches leben
schließen lässt ich drücke euch
jedenfalls die daumen einfach auf sie
hier klicken oder hier draufklicken oder
auf den link im ersten kommentar oder in
der video beschreibung bis dann bleibt
dran